ja willkommen zum seminareinführung in
die politische Philosophie ich möchte
hier in der ersten Sitzung ersten Teil
dieser Reihe kurz erklären was das Ziel
des Seminars ist was man auch online auf
viele lukasten folgen kann mir geht es
zunächst darum eine historische
Orientierung im politischen zu erlangen
was auch immer das politische ist
darüber werden wir noch genauer dann
sprechen und vor allem geht es mir darum
eine begriffliche Orientierung im
politischen zu erhalten also nicht nur
bezogen auf historische Positionen
Platon Aristoteles Thomas von Aquin und
so weiter sondern auch anhand der
systematischen Probleme die im Bereich
des politischen in der Reflexion und das
politische von zentraler Bedeutung sind
ohne die wir das politische gar nicht in
seinen verschiedenen Dimensionen auch
Probleme erfassen können
und es führt zum dritten Ziel drittens
geht es mir darum eine kritische
Orientierung im politischen zu erlangen
das bedeutet wir müssen gegenüber
bestimmten Phänomenen des politischen
wie zum Beispiel macht oder Ideologie
besonders kritisch sein weil macht
häufig so
gestaltet sein kann dass sie
Partizipation also
demokratische liberale Strukturen
ausschließt genauso ist es mit der
Ideologie
Ideologien dienen häufig dazu macht
illegitim also nicht
gerechtfertigterweise zu erlangen oder
auch zu steigern zumindest zu sichern
und gegenüber solchen Phänomenen ihm
politischen müssen wir auch besonders
kritisch sein das ist natürlich wieder
voraus dass wir ein historische und eine
begriffliche Orientierung besitzen
drei Phänomene gibt es jetzt die die
kritische Orientierung besonders
betreffend ich habe schon einmal gesagt
Herrschaft ist ganz wichtig
herrschaftslegitimierung
Herrschaftssicherung
geschäftssteigerung
herrschaftsdurchsetzung macht die
natürlich immer wichtig ist um
Herrschaft zu
legitimieren oder genauer gesagt
aufrecht zu erhalten und Ideologie
Ideologie legitimiert ihr die Herrschaft
kognitiv also das ist dann das
ideologische was durch das Denken die
Herrschaft stärkt oder auch überhaupt
erst zustande kommen lässt die macht
hingegen ist das nicht so sehr kognitiv
ist sondern ihr ja
real im Moment das uns am Ende
Herrschaft erlangen lässt
jetzt möchte ich noch mal ganz kurz
zunächst sagen was es eigentlich
politische Philosophie dazu muss man
sich überlegen was ist eigentlich
Philosophie und was ist Politik ist dann
können wir das zusammengesetzte
Philosophie
Terminus Gebilde politische Philosophie
verstehen das heißt wir fangen mal an
was ist eigentlich Philosophie da gibt
es natürlich auch sehr viele Auffassung
darüber so viele Auffassung wie es auch
Philosophen und Philosophen gibt dennoch
wollen wir uns jetzt mal dieser Frage
annähern was ist Philosophie ich habe
hier ein Vorschlag der ist natürlich
immer
diskussionsfähig Philosophie ist eine
methodisch geleitete Reflexion auf die
Grundbegriffe und Grundprobleme der
menschlichen Existenz
warum methodisch reflektiert weil man
natürlich einfach auch so nur
reflektieren kann und das ist noch lange
nicht Philosophie Philosophie muss
logisch widerspruchsfrei vollzogen
werden und die Grundbegriffe und Grund
Probleme sind nicht Probleme die einfach
äußerlich sind sondern sie betreffen den
Kern der Sache also wir müssen erstmal
überhaupt herausfinden was der Kern der
Sache ist und dann müssen wir die
methodisch logisch
widerspruchsfrei geordnet verständlich
darüber nachdenken was ist Politik
Politik oder das politische ist
derjenige Bereich unseres Zusammenlebens
durch Regeln der Herrschaft Herrschaft
hat mir schon als Begriff und
Mitbestimmung Partizipation definiert
ist der kommt von griechischen Tat
Politiker das bedeutet das politische
ist ein pluralwort dasjenige was das
Gemeinwesen die Police betrifft die
antiken Griechenland gab es verschiedene
Police Stadtstaaten Athen war eine
solche Polys und die war eben auch
bestimmt oder definiert durch Regeln der
Herrschaft man hat sich damals darüber
sehr die Köpfe zermartet welches System
ist das Beste für unser Zusammenleben
für das politische ist es die Demokratie
kreativ bedeutet immer Herrschaft ist
die Volksherrschaft ist es die
Herrschaft der wenigen der Olli ist die
oligographie oder ist es Oligarchie oder
ist es die Herrschaft der Vermögenden
die
Plutokratie oder ist es die Herrschaft
der besten die sogenannte Aristokratie
man sieht hier gab es schon seit der
Antike
viel Diskussion zu diesem Thema und wenn
das jetzt das politische ist dann ist
die politische Philosophie ganz einfach
eine methodisch geleitete Reflexion auf
die Grundbegriffe und Grundprobleme
unseres Herrschaft und Mitbestimmung
definiertem zusammen leben
so viel zu Definition jetzt möchte ich
noch abschließend auf historische und
systematische Dimensionen des
politischen des politischen
Philosophierens eingehen
zu historischen Dimension gibt es
natürlich jede Menge Denkerinnen und
Denker die hier zentral sind ich möchte
mal eine ganze prominente Reihe nennen
das sind Platon Aristoteles die antiken
griechischen Philosophen Augustinus
Thomas von der Queen die ihr
christlichen Philosophen einmal der das
Ausgehen der ausgehenden Antike der
später des Mittelalters Machiavelli der
Früh Neuzeit da geht es um Macht der
Fürst ist ein sein Werk das er
geschrieben hat Thomas Horbs ein
englischer Philosoph da geht es darum
ein
Staatswesen zu erschaffen was sehr viel
Macht in sich vereint das ist der
sogenannte Leviathan bei John Lock geht
es um Verträge genauso bei so um den
Gesellschaftsvertrag Immanuel hat sich
Gedanken gemacht zum ewigen Frieden Karl
Marx und Friedrich Engels über den
Kommunismus John Stuart Mill über die
Nützlichkeit
Utilitarismus der natürlich auch
politische Dimensionen hat Hannah Arendt
hat sich insbesondere mit der Ideologie
totalitäre Herrschaften wie dem
Nationalsozialismus befasst John rolls
mit dem Thema Gerechtigkeit Michelle
fuku auch mit Macht Durchsetzungen die
insbesondere auch Diskriminierung
betreffen
Oppositionen gesund krank solche
Kategorisierungen hat er besonders
betrachtet Jürgen habermaß zuletzt zu
nehmen hier die Theorie des kommunikativ
Handelns also wie sollten wir im
politischen durch unsere Sprache auch
interagieren und das politische
durchsprachlich Interaktion zu
rechtfertigen und in eine gerechte Form
zu überführen aus systematischer Sicht
in der Begriff der Global Gerechtigkeit
der Freiheit
kontrakturismus also Vertragstheorie
kommunetarismus also die Theorie die
sich ihr gegen die Individualisierung
Wende die die Gemeinschaft betont auch
wenn sie nicht dasselbe ist wie
Kommunismus Vernunft kommunikative von
uns machtrecht Herrschaft Ideologien
internationale Politik sind wichtige
Themen
zwei Bücher möchte ich noch am Schluss
empfehlen einmal hier am reklam-verlag
die Texte zu politischen Philosophie die
enthalten sehr viele von denen genannten
Denkern und Denkerinnen als Auszüge und
dann noch hier die ihr lehrbuchsartig
gehalten Einführung in die politische
Philosophie mittlerweile in der dritten
Auflage von Christopher ja das war eine
kurze Einführung in das Seminar vielen
Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit